what's going on guys this is rob and dr
strange two got a plot synopsis as of
about a day ago which basically confirms
the appearance of alternate realities
now we kind of knew that like alternate
realities would essentially be in the
movie what the synopsis seems to
indicate is that we're actually going to
see these alternate realities like
doctor strange is going to go there and
spend some time there and so here's what
the plot synopsis reads and then we'll
basically talk about the only two
alternate realities they should really
have in this movie and uh and why it
would be cool for the doctor strange to
film so here's what the synopsis says in
marvel studios doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness the mcu unlocks
the multiverse and pushes its boundaries
further than ever before
journey into the unknown with dr strange
who with the help of mystical allies
both old and new traverses the
mind-bending and dangerous alternate
realities of the multiverse to confront
a mysterious new adversary now having
said that uh there's only two alternate
realities they need to have in this
movie right those are guys who are
familiar with comics you guys are gonna
know what i'm talking about because
we've covered both of these over at
comics explain we covered the whole
original story arc for the first one and
then for the second one uh we covered
the whole storyline which was
ridiculously cool these alternate
realities are marvel ruins
and the cancer verse so here's the thing
right the cancer verse would make more
sense due to the events of like
schumachorath or gargantos honestly okay
you know what let's let's talk about
this for a second when they do the whole
gargantos thing i told people right off
the bat that's not gargantuas that's
schuma gorath no way is anybody gonna
believe that it makes sense for a
one-eyed octopus who died in the same
comic he appeared in to be like the
overwhelming force of doctor strange
come to find out it's basically
copyright rules and so because disney
doesn't own the rights to the name
schumacher they have to call him
gargantos i don't care it's shumogorath
they could call him tim the [ __ ]
octopus and it would still work right
it's chumagorath this multiversal just
evil just straight-up evil entity that
wants to conquer the universe that's
fine or universes that's fine i don't
care what they call them it's schumacher
i was right so here's the thing uh let's
talk about marvel ruins for a second
marvel ruins was this story we covered
this over our comments explain marvel
ruins was a story written by a guy named
warren ellis it was dark if it was bad
it happened right okay so here's the
thing let's take a couple of examples
here right the incredible hulk and then
let's talk about the x-men which was a
really really crazy thing the whole
basis behind marvel ruins was that
instead of the main marvel universe
seeing things happening the way that it
did it happened in a much darker tone so
when you take somebody like bruce
spanner who was basically at ground zero
when the gamma bomb went off in the main
marvel universe he becomes the
incredible hulk right in marvel ruins
he's a hulk but he's a hulking mass of
irradiated tumors right literally like
they're just like he's caught in the
gamma blast he just starts expanding out
into all these tumors and everything and
then just dies and it's just like wow
like that's that's crazy it's absolutely
horrendous with the x-men it was worse
man okay so here's the thing so what you
end up finding out here oh by the way
one of the things that marvel ruins
which is kind of funny you guys know who
enchantress is right she's like the
really luscious woman who's drawn in a
very voluptuous way in marvel comics she
ends up becoming a porn star and she
kills her manager you don't see it they
actually write about it basically like
the little pages at the very end of the
story uh but that's one little things
you get in marvel ruins so basically
professor xavier he is the president of
the united states you're not explicitly
told that he has powers but it's alluded
to that he has telepathy and that he
used his powers to make himself
president of the united states his
assistant is warren worthington also
known as angel if you don't know who
that is he's the guy that basically has
angel's wings you've seen him even if
you don't know what his name is but the
thing here is that instead of professor
xavier doing what he always did which
was trying to create peaceful
coexistence between like humans and
mutants this guy is a dick so what he
ends up doing is basically opening up
what are in effect concentration camps
it's just these super gruesome things
that in order to control the powers of
the mutants that are out there they're
often forced to undergo like these
gruesome experiments so like with
cyclops for example for those of you
guys who don't know how cyclops powers
work his eyes are basically portals to a
dimension of pure energy and so when he
opens his eyes that energy just comes
pouring out right it just it shoots out
in the form of optic blast right
concussive energy and so what ended up
happening in marvel ruins is that when
his powers manifested he incinerated his
family by accident he was taken to a
concentration camp and they blinded him
they like welded his eyes shut right
it's just it's it's crazy kitty pride of
course as you guys know has the ability
to like move through solid objects in
marvel ruins she was taken to the
concentration camp when she tried to
escape she got stuck in the door and
lost three feet of her intestines it's
crazy the kind of things that happen to
these guys then there's mystique and
magneto and their fates are gruesome if
you can even imagine such a thing so the
thing about this is that mystique has
the ability to shape shift but because
she's changed into so many different
people over the years she basically
starts losing her mind right she ends up
going through what i guess now is
referred to as disassociative identity
disorder i guess multiple personality
disorders considered an antiquated term
i feel like that's the most accurate
term a person with multiple
personalities multiple personality
disorder i don't know but regardless the
thing is uh she ends up basically losing
her mind right she ends up going through
like all these crazy switches in terms
of her physical appearance and i think
there's at one point where she's like an
entire amalgamation of all these
different people that she's copied now
while that's going on magneto is a guy
who can control magnetism but he can't
control it in a finite way the way he's
able to do in the main marvel universe
he really has no control over it at all
and so what he has is this harness on
his body that basically allows him to
control his magnetic powers that way
well things start popping off and
ultimately the harness that's on his
body is basically destroyed and when
that happens he loses control of his
magnetic powers and starts pulling in
everything around him at the airport
right because everything with mystique
is all going on at the airport while
she's on a plane everything gets pulled
into him and there's just like this
colossal explosion right i mean marvel
ruins is bleak when the video was made
for comments explained we called it like
the worst case scenario or like like
though like everything bad happens in
the universe something like that it was
something along those lines but
basically like it's the most bleak
possible outcome for any particular
universe in marvel comics in relation to
like the superheroes on earth it's nuts
now to top this all off right the last
little tidbit that we'll have before we
move on to the cancer verse what ends up
happening is with peter parker
spider-man because all these people are
developing powers peter wants powers too
so he exposes himself to radiation and
then dies of radiation sickness but the
guy who's traveling around and narrating
this whole story had shaken hands with
peter parker and was exposed to the same
radiation which ultimately kills him but
it's just this unnecessarily bleak and
overly dark story now
let's switch over to something called
the cancer verse which is still pretty
dark but not nearly as bleak as marvel
ruins right so cancerverse was part of a
storyline called the thanos imperative
its story actually kind of comes out a
little bit before that right so what you
had in marvel comics was an event called
the war of kings so the idea behind the
war of kings is that you basically had
vulcan who led a group called the shiar
empire and you had black bolt of the
inhumans who at that point in time was
leading the kree empire how those two
got to that point doesn't really matter
here but they end up going to war with
each other now because this war is
literally an intergalactic war it
basically leads to like this fissure
being ripped in space when they're like
detonating their weapons and different
things like that no one knows what's on
the other side of this rift but you
basically have like people who are
tasked with monitoring it what you also
get is like occasionally something will
come out but that thing is usually
destroyed so there's not really a whole
lot of concern there but they send
probes into the other side and nothing
ever happens and so one day while you
have like the guardians of the galaxy
you have all these people suddenly the
universal church of truth appears out of
nowhere and when i say up here i mean
like it's all the ships of the universal
church of truth and all the planets
occupied by by like devoted members of
the universal church of truth whole
planets right like and we're talking
about planets that range in size from
like earth to jupiter right just huge
planets and so what ends up happening is
that with this fissure being relatively
thin right not really enough to like get
a whole bunch of stuff in or out just a
small little thing right it's like uh
it's like a crack in a wall with water
just kind of trickling out right the
universal church of truth under the
direction of the magus i think it was
detonates everything right like the
planets the ships the whole nine yards
they just blow it all up right they all
just commit mass suicide and they ripped
this fissure wide open when that happens
sun sun sun all hell breaks loose like
it's just all these things right just
just like ships and everything all come
pouring out it's a full-scale invasion
from an alternate reality now at this
point in time you've got the guardians
of the galaxy you've got the cree you've
got the scroll you've got the shield you
have everyone right everyone is there
minus the earth superheroes for the most
part but it's just like this colossal
battle in space it's nuts and so then
you end up getting basically the
annihilators now here's the thing those
of you guys who don't read comics the
annihilators were like the most
overpowered team in the history of
marvel comics until we got al ewing's
ultimates right so this team and i don't
remember everybody on the team but just
to give you guys like the heavy hitters
this was like silver surfer beta ray
bill quasar uh nova these are guys that
could like manipulate cosmic energy in
some form or fashion and beta ray bill
had actually had a power upgrade up to
that point right i mean cosmic entities
are there like galactus is there i mean
it's just it's this just crazy situation
right now for the most part the heroes
are able to hold their own right the
guardians of the galaxy actually end up
having thanos right they had resurrected
him following his death at the hands of
draxler destroyer during annihilation so
the guardians of the galaxy have like
they have thanos and like did like like
basically the name of our universe is
holding its own against these forces
right like they're basically kind of
able to hold them at bay they're able to
sort of push them back
and then like this just
face comes out of this fissure right and
it's the head of galactus from this
alternate reality it's like a skull
right what these guys had done is they
had basically
converted galactus into what was in
effect a giant gun it's like if galactus
was like the death star from star wars
that's basically what this was right now
keep in mind keep in mind right
superheroes we can call them that right
the good guys right the main level
universe teams groups races all that
kind of stuff they're all here right
they've got just giant huge craft right
just ships that are just like colossal
in size right just heavy firepower all
that stuff you've got guys like the
silver surfer who can manipulate the
power cosmic and all that kind of stuff
right this galactus engine as they call
right the galactus engine comes out and
then it's just like
and it just like annihilates like just
huge sections of these forces right at
that point the heroes are just like fall
back right like we gotta get the hell
out of here right like they're all
they're all ready to run right like the
ones who stay are like we have to
destroy that thing but like huge
portions of the of the fighting group
are just like no we ain't messing with
that kind of firepower right they bail
right it's a crazy thing now here's what
had happened in the cancer verse and
here's the reason why this would work so
well in doctor strange too even if we
don't get like this huge massive battle
or anything like that to be able to see
it would be great so in the main marvel
universe what you had was a storyline
called the death of captain marvel right
marvel of the cree one of the most
significant superheroes in the history
of marvel comics in the main marvel
universe he died of cancer right cancer
is kind of like this just omnipotent
thing that exists out there in marvel
comics like shy of using the infinity
gauntlet and seemingly that can't even
do the trick you can't cure somebody of
cancer right so if you were a person
that had like a healing factor it
wouldn't be able to to fix cancer
because at that point you're asking your
body cells to destroy themselves and so
seemingly it wouldn't really work that
way but the important thing here is that
marvel made peace with his death and
then basically passed on what ends up
happening in the cancer verse is that
instead of that being the case in that
alternate reality marvel had brought
together seemingly all of his friends
and then had dr strange cast a spell
that killed mistress death in their
universe so no one could die now that in
and of itself is not the worst thing it
becomes a problem right because
basically you have like overpopulation
of a universe right a universe with just
life filled to the brim what ended up
happening and i believe doctor strange
was the vector by way this took place is
that you ended up having the mini angled
ones those guys who don't know what that
is the mini angled ones are basically
like the brick between the mortar they
exist between the universes and that
beings like schumacherath are basically
mini angled ones shumogorath is the rare
occasion where a mini angled one
basically managed to take over a
universe and then start hopping from
universe to universe expanding his fear
of influence but like the many angled
ones are just like these old eldritch
monsters they're just ridiculously
powerful well one of them or a group of
them had managed to basically get a hold
of doctor strange and then convince dr
strange to bring them into the universe
again i'm pretty sure it's doctor
strange but i'm not gonna swear to that
we're just gonna say that it is uh and
then ultimately when the many angled
ones invaded into the universe they
corrupted everybody right so like
literally instead of it being like the
avengers they're the revengers and
they're all basically evil but what's
basically happening here is they're all
basically being led by captain marvel
and maybe it was mar-vell who had been
been you know had basically lured the
many angled ones and or been manipulated
by the the many angled ones to invite
them into the universe whatever the case
is marvell is basically the one who
leads them and so because death doesn't
exist there none of them can die and the
goal the first and foremost goal here is
to find mistress death in the maine
marvel universe and kill her so they
don't have to worry about her using her
powers to kill them as soon as they
enter into that place now while all this
is going on right just this massive
battle in space while all this is going
on
thanos richard ryder and star-lord peter
quill sneak into the cancer verse where
marvel is at they end up facing off
against like some crazy guys right like
the incredible hulk who's got like horns
on his head he looks pretty beast right
not even gonna lie but they end up
sneaking into that universe and then
eventually find marvel and one of the
crazy things is marvel is like what do
you possibly hope to accomplish here i
can't die in this universe right like
i'm completely immortal and thanos and
i'm kind of paraphrasing here thanos is
like oh no i didn't come to kill you
she did and like he kneels and mistress
death is behind him and you just get
this ridiculously amazing moment she
doesn't really say it but it's just it's
something that they should have said in
the comic right like let there be death
upon this universe like mistress death
touches marvel and kills him and then
death is reintroduced to the universe
balance is restored and all the beings
that are supposed to die are basically
destroyed it's just it's it's the cancer
versus an amazing storyline but the rift
actually ends up closing and then i
believe thanos and richard ryder are
stuck on the other side in the cancer
verse and star-lord's the only one who
makes it out and so like thanos and
richard ryder just gone for years and
more comments now finishing our little
comments explained-esque moment here
right let's tie this into doctor strange
one of the things that's happening here
is that while doctor strange is now
officially being billed it's kind of
like an action fantasy film that one of
the things that we've consistently seen
in terms of how it's been talked about
is that doctor strange is by all
standards of measurement going to be a
kind of horror movie or it's going to
have dark elements to that movie now do
i expect us to see the full totality of
the cancer verse from the thanos
imperative or see the entire story arc
of marvel ruins here in that movie no
but i do think it would be cool to see
him end up in those universes where
things are just that bad where no one
can die but they're all corrupted by the
many angled ones the aspect of the
cancer verse would actually make a lot
more sense because it would show the
gravity of what would happen if
schumacherath is successful that he's
not going to destroy all life across the
universe he's not like thanos where he's
going to blink out half the life in
existence because of some you know
misguided attempt to restore balance to
everything that schumacherath is going
to conquer it he's going to subjugate
everyone and anybody who gets in this
way is going to die right like so in
that cancerverse storyline all the
cosmic entities eternity infinity
oblivion all those guys they're gone
right they're dead and gone and out of
the picture like that's that's it like
like galactus was even defeated right so
i mean like the many angled ones were
able to conquer that entire universal
space and that whole introduction of
that concept could be this is the fate
that awaits us
if we fail right that's what this means
like this is this is what will happen
this is what our universe and every
other universe across the cosmos will
turn into i just like the idea of marvel
ruins because i'm i'm i'm kinda dark i
like seeing just some brutal stuff
happen to characters and comic books i
don't know why i'm just a little
obsessed with that it's a little weird i
know it's not probably not healthy but
the important thing is i think it'd be
cool to see that i mean if i had to
choose between one of the two i would
choose the cancer verse right i would
choose that one but in the end i think
these these things could work great
because what doctor strange two needs is
gravitas it needs us to have that kind
of villain and what the stakes are right
it's one thing to say that like
schumacher is the bad guy okay well why
should we go at the bad guy i mean what
why does it matter if shumogorath
conquered the universe because of
schumacher conquered the universe and
everybody was able to just spend their
lives living happily and never having to
worry about anything and just being able
to do whatever it was that made them
happy well hey that don't sound so bad i
mean that sounds pretty cool right
schumacher i have conquered your
universe and now everyone gets a billion
dollars that doesn't sound so terrible
it sounds kind of awesome to be honest
with you i mean if that's what she
maratho's gonna do i'd be like hey bro
i'm right here home slice let me get
that money right cheddar comment but if
jim mcgrath is showing up in the
universe for the purpose of just
subjugating it right conquering it and
turning everybody into these dark and
twisted and evil versions of themselves
that's horrifying right that's
terrifying everybody's just evil dark
and twisted if they gave it a kind of
like rise of cthulhu sort of element
right words like masteria death
pandemonium all that kind of stuff right
the end times that would be great i
would absolutely love that so it's one
of those things where it's like we all
have to team up and defeat shumogorath
he's the main bad guy like we've seen
him do this in universe after universe
after universe after universe right that
he somehow came by way of the
multiverse's return or possibly he was
locked away outside the multiverse
whatever it is right by whatever manner
and whatever means he has now been freed
and he is now out there in the
multiverse wreaking havoc and if we
don't stop him this is the fate that
awaits all of us so let me know what you
guys think down in the comments right
like would you guys want to see
something like that right these kind of
alternate realities and if there's any
kind of other alternate realities you
want me to talk about that you would
want us to see in the in the movie let
me know man because there's some crazy
alternate realities out there in marvel
comics and we're not even talking about
stuff like age of ultron or anything
along those lines right there's some
crazy stuff like the crooked world
universe that would be cool i don't know
how you tie that into doctor strange
outside of just saying like there's this
guy named imagine jaspers who can alter
reality and they had destroyed his
universe so he wouldn't corrupt the
multiverse and like that said right i
mean i don't know how you really build
on that or do anything that we could you
know we could tie in dr strange but let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace